[Music]
let's get a new tape going all right
Richard here's what we're gonna do we
need a voice exemplar I want you to say
into this phone there's a bomb in
Centennial Park you have 30 minutes
Richard your national hero now thank you
sir but I'll just doing my job you
always look at the guy who found the
bomb just like he was attacked on the by
jewel fits the profile of the lone
bomber a frustrated white man who is a
police wannabe who seeks to become a
hero we're running it you're a suspect
you don't talk I talk safe
Auto tone this might be the only way to
clear your name I want you to say
there's a bomb in Centennial Park you
have 30 minutes stop trying to be the
best friend I was raised to respect
authorities looking to eat you alive
it's a bomb in Centennial Park you have
30 minutes I'm sorry what his accusers
are two of the most powerful forces in
the world the United States government
and the media I do want to help you out
law enforcement to me there is a bomb in
Centennial Park you have 30 minutes
Richard Jewell is an innocent man he's a
hero
there's a bomb in Centennial Park you
have 30 minutes
one more times a little louder I report
the facts you Brewin this man's loss
there's a bomb in Centennial Park you
have 30 minutes to a couple of rooms
son saved people's lives
[Music]
there is a balm in Centennial Park
Hallman Centennial Park you have 30
minutes I don't think how to protect you
but your client is guilty as out they
want to fire you
you're going to start fighting back
[Music]
[Music]